first question I have for you is which
characters Arc change the most from how
you originally envisioned their
evolution panning out day one of working
on the Guardians Trilogy and then who
else like stayed truest to what you
originally envisioned for them uh the
most different was cragland because I
had just he was just the first mate who
I gave a name to and I didn't know that
he was going to become such a main part
of the guardians galaxy I never would
have thought he was gonna be on the
poster with a head fin that just kind of
developed
um and also because it was cheaper
because we already had hired Sean for uh
rocket and so we saved money by also
giving him another character but I will
say uh rocket and uh and quill and
nebula were very close to what I
originally envisioned from the beginning
special arcs right there going into that
Chris for you so he has been through a
lot of really pivotal moments of all of
the ones that happened in Guardians one
and two is there any particular scene or
thing he experienced that you find
influencing your performance the most in
the choices he makes in Guardians 3.
probably what happened in Infinity war
and end game you know with Gamora dying
that's got to have the biggest impact on
volume three certainly he had found him
he had found who he was in her eyes and
his love for her and so when she when he
looks in those eyes and doesn't see that
anymore it's it's pretty heartbreaking
and I think that resonates to the course
of the whole uh volume very much so this
question is going to make me sad but
just to theorize a little what do you
think the future would have held for him
if the original Gamora was still there
how might has his path have been
different oh I think that they were in
love I think the next natural step is
that they would have started a family
and and uh been happy to be together I
suppose I don't know why I just asked
sex now I'm even sadder that it didn't
happen he would have probably blown it
though he would have been like he would
he would have screwed it up somehow
hopefully otherwise it's you know
wouldn't be a great movie
oh that oh that good for the that'd be
good
that'd be good that'd be good I'm not
allowed to ask any spoilers James but I
did want to ask you this particular
question because a lot of people just
assume that in order to continue raising
stakes in a series like this you have to
kill off characters so more broadly can
you tell us a little bit about your
approach to either you know needing a
death because the story justifies it and
you have to build Stakes versus keeping
a character alive and when that kind of
satisfaction is necessary I don't think
that
um
a killing characters necessary you know
one of the things I've discovered over
the years as as I've killed characters
in different movies people know that I'm
willing to do that so you know I killed
I killed no yondu died in volume two you
know original group died in volume one
in suicide squad I killed everybody uh
practically you know uh I killed a major
character in Peacemaker so people know
I'm a guy who's willing to go there and
I think that the movies have to feel
like that whether it's true or not the
movies have to feel like you know their
lives are really at stake and in most
movies I don't feel like that
um you know I think you know in some
cases I don't think we really think that
you know Tom Cruise and Mission
Impossible is gonna die you know but but
for the most part you need to feel that
sense of stakes
um and I think that's what's important
more so than actually killing someone
and it's all it's all a function of
story and if someone dies it shouldn't
be I try not to have people die that die
and are just there to service another
character it has to work as a part of
the story
um and isn't just
um
you know well I mean that's not true in
the case of like you know the guys from
the beginning of the suicide squad like
that was you know just kind of killing
them because it's funny but uh but in
but if they're a real story like I would
never have killed yondu just to kill
yondu it had to be intimately involved
with the story and I didn't want to kill
yondu Michael Rooker is one of my very
close friends and you know and I had him
surviving in my first draft because I
want to work with Rooker again and I
wanted to put him in the next movie and
it just came to me that this is this is
what this is about you know Peter Quill
has to lose this character in his life
and yandu has to sacrifice his life he
has to come through this is his
Redemption and he can only do that by
sacrificing his life so I knew it was
the right ending for the story and I'm
always in service to that again no
spoilers but how you handle all that
stuff in this particular movie is
exceptional and very well earned Chris
for you I love hearing everybody sing
James's Praises so whether it's in movie
three or any of the previous movies you
worked on together can you give me an
example of a time where you are having a
tough time cracking a scene and some
collaboration or a note he gave you made
all the difference no I can't think
so I'll make something up every
everything
oh my gosh I truly it'd be hard to zero
in on any one I guess what would come to
the top of my head
uh early on in a lot more probably in
volume one and then also in volume two
it
we developed a shorthand over the course
of working together all these years in
volume one I remember there was a note I
tell people this and they think it makes
you sound like a real dick but it's
actually an amazing thing so I'm gonna
tell it because uh I loved an
opportunity to make you look like a dick
um uh there was a scene where my
character is saying blue Suite hooked on
a feeling that song belongs to me and it
was important for it to be
in in hindsight now looking at it I know
what James was trying to get out of me
and he got it out of me I think which
was like this it's great really strong
energetic loud
emotional plea to not lose this song I
was having a hard time getting there as
an actor and it also I couldn't justify
why I would say it in a way that was
like the way he wanted it it was hard
for me to see the forest through the
trees he had an eye on the forest so I
was looking at the tree and I'm like
this doesn't feel like the right tree
and so I said but I kept saying you know
what I feel but here's what I feel this
and he goes it doesn't matter what you
feel
it doesn't matter what you feel okay it
matters what I think
oh okay and he in that moment I it
obviously does matter what an actor
feels but
the the North Star is his vision and his
vision for that was just something that
I couldn't see at the time and then in
seeing the movie I was like oh that's
that's what he was looking to do and it
took me a while to get there it was
embarrassing to get there and I thought
that when I did that take in the moment
it was almost like a Fu I'll give you
exactly what you asked for and then he
put it in I was like oh that was really
great that's exactly what he wanted so I
I really learned it especially in that
moment trust him I I I will say like
that's actually I don't the second part
I don't remember saying but maybe it
doesn't matter what I think yeah it does
it matters what I think yeah it doesn't
matter what you feel yeah yeah I said
that one time to Elizabeth Banks too she
was doing this ridiculous thing and and
I said what the are you doing like
she's wiping up the glass on the ground
with a book and she said why are you
stomping on my self-expression and I
said this movie isn't about your
self-expression it's about mine yeah I'm
joking but the thing is about it but
it's really important to me like I say
this all the time some you know that I
tell actors it does doesn't matter what
you feel and it doesn't that doesn't
mean it doesn't matter what you feel as
a human being I care about I don't want
to hurt his feelings as a human being or
have him feel bad as a human being but
actors often get caught up in the scene
I'm supposed to be sad I have to feel
sad but you don't have to feel sad you
just have to appear the you know the on
screen in the way you're supposed to be
and actors get so hung up on what
they're supposed to feel and you don't
have any real control over your feelings
so when I tell an actor it doesn't
matter what you feel it to me it's a
compassionate thing to help them let go
of this burden that they carry to try to
feel a certain way and allow them to use
the tools they have and the craft of
acting to get to the spot where they can
you know probably will actually feel
what they want to feel in the first
place but you can't get there by trying
to feel something okay
ideal leader and I'll use your term a
North star there so when you're
functioning as a North star in a a
series I am wondering with what lies
ahead for you what is something about
being a leader on a series that you
think you learn from guardians that
you'll carry over to DC but then also
what's a tool in that particular toolkit
that felt specific to Marvel and
Guardians that you're starting to feel
you know is Left Behind and specific to
that well honestly I really miss my my
friendship I'm not my friendship because
I'm still friends but I'll miss my
relationship with Kevin and Lou because
I really like those guys and they are
incredibly helpful and you know and you
know Kevin's not as you know he lets us
kind of do our own thing more so than on
like the first movie where he was around
a little more but like he made one
really big change he made one suggestion
for volume three that was really helpful
and so I'll really miss that wisdom and
the friendship
um I think that uh you know I just I I
really believe that the lyrics of Kenny
Rogers Gambler uh have the uh all the
clues for being a filmmaker which is you
gotta know when to hold them know when
to fold them when no one to walk away
and know when to run and that is with
every single thing that I do on the
movie you have to know when to to fight
and you need to know when to to chill
out and back down and that has to do
with other filmmakers it has to do with
you know actors it has to do with
producers it has to do with Studio heads
um you have to know how to sort of
ooze your way through things in a
um in a kind way
that's what it all comes down to it's
what it always should come down to I
wish everybody operated that way thank
you congratulations seriously